today's new member of the day is Cheryl
Gator Cheryl thank you for being a david
pakman show member really appreciate it
and I also want to say thanks to Rebecca
capless known as Becky
K+ who's been with us since 2013 I know
Becky personally she's a great person
she is more responsible for the success
of the David Pakman show then most
people in the audience know let me put
it that way let me put it that way so
great day to be a new member of the day
for Cheryl Gator the same day that Becky
K+ is longtime member of the day and on
that note we will go to the phone 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 50 let's see what's on people's
minds starting with our caller from 972
caller from 9 7 to go ahead hey David
this is Duncan
go ahead Duncan what's going on um so
I've been watching your show for a long
time and a huge fan that you learned a
few people that I actually agree with on
a lot of things oh good well one thing
I'm not fully understanding is why it's
important or what the significance of
Trump's saying the n-word like why does
it matter we already know that he has
some racial tendencies why is it news
that he would say an n-word or a
specific word in general it's you're
completely right Duncan that anybody who
has followed Donald Trump for the last
two years wouldn't be at all shocked
that Donald Trump uses the n-word in
fact it's very likely that he does it
would be newsworthy for two reasons and
to be clear I have made it clear from
the beginning that the n-word story is
is not actually a top story right we've
got dozens of indictments and guilty
verdicts coming against Trump associ
lorries are other stories it's relevant
sort of for two reasons number one it
would be sort of like the final
debasement of the culture if Trump were
on video throwing the N word around and
his supporters didn't care which is
probably what would happen like there
would probably be no repercussions to
that when the truth is that the lack of
decorum that we've already seen should
have had consequences and that would
sort of be like the final straw but
you're right that like big picture
it's not that crazy as a revelation
because any reasonable person at this
point probably assumes Trump uses the
word right and it I I don't understand
why people are making this a bigger deal
than it really is I think I don't know
we made a bigger deal than it is
I mean I I think it's a salacious story
that involves Omarosa and all of these
different elements but the president on
tape using a word he claims isn't in his
vocabulary does further go to his
pathological lying does further go to
lying about his views about minorities
like it's not nothing but I do agree
with you that it's not by any means the
biggest even on the day that it was the
story it wasn't the biggest story that
day no I agree that I think it's the
fact that Omarosa had recordings to
begin with that Jews in the security
room and had recordings and not just the
n-word I think his Trump's very very
loyal fan base I think would be more
relieved that a president would use such
a word because they already connect with
the cadences and the way he talks to
begin with yeah listen
Omarosa is a black woman and she's
recording him secretly he should be
calling her the n-word according to some
of trumps supporters
exactly yeah all right Duncan very good
I appreciate the call thank you so much
doesn't sound like we're in total
disagreement just uh maybe maybe good to
clarify I guess we can say